so go ahead so tell us oh yeah yeah
marxism okay let me start with the
things i don't agree with okay i don't
think that work is like inherently
oppression you know he really thought
that it was like that labor was
oppression
um i don't think that i think there's
dignity in labor and i don't think you
can get self-esteem from something
somebody gives you like you can only get
it by working for it and so i totally
don't disagree with marx on that i
disagree that the only thing between
people is power he was sort of like he
got that from hegel but like that idea
that like we should replace a worldview
based on right versus wrong with the
worldview based on who has power and who
doesn't or that anybody who employs
someone is you know in a relationship
that's oppressive i don't believe in any
of that you know obviously i don't
believe in what he thought about
religion i think that religion's really
really important um to a function
how do you mean by religion what was his
view on religion you're saying karl marx
let him go through it yeah
he's like
like he was like a materialistic you
know he was materialism yeah yeah i
don't believe any of that and an atheist
type of deal um and and i'm very against
like critical race theory which is they
took the marxist um you know it was
really a hegelian binary and they
applied it to race and said okay
that power binary right that barks
thought was like between like the the
bourgeoisie the boss and then the
laborer right where the only thing
between those two was a power imbalance
and oppression in critical race theory
they say you have white people and
people of color and it's that same thing
right like people white people have all
the power and their only relationship
with people of color is oppressive i
think that's all disgusting and terrible
and gross and wrong and what the worst
people to ever walk planet earth
believed so i'm i don't believe any of
that but i would like to say that like
the problem with critical race theory is
the insufficiency of marxism
not that it's marxist because what i
mean by that is to me what marx got
right i don't know if it was true for
his moment but in our moment right now
fundamentally the divide in america is
not about politics and it's not about
race it's about class we have a huge
class divide in america that separates
the college educated you know from the
working class like that that is the
fundamental reality of american life if
you have a college degree you will make
on average a million dollars more over
the course of your lifetime than if you
don't you will have better health you
will live longer and your children will
be upwardly mobile you will have access
to the american dream and if you don't
increasingly you won't increasingly you
will die sooner your body will break
down earlier you'll face deaths of
despair i mean it's bad right and you
will not have access to the american
dream increasingly you won't be able to
buy a home you won't be able to access
that next level so that divide like i'm
seeing that through a clock that's
seeing it through a class analysis using
the lens of class to understand the real
struggles in america that to me is
marxist but the reason i say i think you
would agree with me is i noticed
something during covet which was that
the the people who opposed the lockdowns
they were doing it
because
yes there was the freedom thing yes but
that wasn't the thing that motivated the
emotional response on the right to these
authoritarian lockdowns what motivated
the emotional response was what
motivated me which was the disgust
with allowing yourself because of your
financial security to rise so far above
the people you relied on to survive
meaning we're gonna enforce a lockdown
because we can work from home right so
we're gonna keep making our money and
protect ourselves from the plague but
we're gonna force you to go out into the
plague and stock those shelves and bring
those packages and bring us that food
and we're gonna then tell you how to
live your life so we're gonna make
there's gonna be nothing out there for
you to do except labor for us right
except deliver our packages right
nothing's gonna be open for you you're
gonna have to brave the plague and go
out into the danger so we can protect
ourselves and then they misunderstood
what was essentially their economic
privilege right of being able to work
from home as virtue they thought they
were more virtuous because they were
staying home right so they they took
this thing that was a class divide where
they really were in such a better
situation than the people who they
relied on to work and keep them alive
and then they wanted to keep that
they they they made that distinction
even bigger and bigger and bigger and
kept pushing for policy to make that
distinction even greater and greater
greater and what i saw on the right was
a marxist disgust with with with the
bourgeoisie with these educated elites
for um creating a situation that
benefited them suddenly their houses
were worth so much more right um but
then and then oh and then the kicker was
as soon as they had a vaccine they were
like oh now you have to take it or you
get fired right like it was so
disgusting and i think that that disgust
is mark's i would call that marxist in
nature it is a disgust with a class
divide that one side is sitting there
benefiting from and then stewing in its
own sort of moral like virtue
while oppressing other people like
that's a marxist analysis of covet and i
i bet you would agree with my analysis
did you read karl marx's book or carlito
none of that is
yeah so let me sign up whatever she is
this is the
man carl's cousin or brother that we
forgot about carlito you got it you got
you got to give her some credit though
that's amazing because the remote
the the college educated remote worker
lifestyle wfh work from anywhere work
from home i'm living in uh tulum now i'm
moving to miami uh hey just but but i
got it
that that's uh that what she's saying is
very accurate versus hey go deliver my
groceries go to the door dash i don't
think that's small that has nothing to
do with marxism
by five percent please that's not
marxism what would you call it that's
that's not a lot of those are
libertarian philosophies that you have
you know where leave people alone and
stop forcing [ __ ] down my like let me
live my life and get the hell out of my
way and stop thinking you're so much
more special than me because you got a
degree and i don't that's not marxism a
part of marx
was
he felt there was people that were
better to be put in charge to lead
others
rather than you know he was the one that
thought most of the people were dumb
that's that's marx's idea was more from
the standpoint of there is us who are
more educated than you and we know
what's right for you to live and you
don't believe in that that's not your
approach so a lot of the marxist
you know i've interviewed probably more
communist on a youtube channel than
anybody has done on youtube i like
talking to communists because you know
it's a great conversation too so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]